[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Ruth and I'm my own away and
this is your news for Monday February
19th so first of all we got some casting
news this week one of the first things
we want to talk about is the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina the Netflix series
has cast their villain Michelle Gomez
who plays Missy and dr. who is going to
be playing madam Satan also marry
Wardell who is one of the teachers in
Sabrina's school and I think this fits
pretty well obviously we've seen her
play a good villain on Doctor Who and a
pretty unhinged one on that so I think
that this fits really well and I'm
excited to see more of where the series
is going especially since it has that
darker tone that the chilling Adventures
comics takes but we don't have any news
about exactly one that's coming out
it'll be on Netflix sometime in 2019
awesome also are you in the mood for a
jewelry heist hi action drama biopic
type of movie good because we've got
great news for you Tessa Thompson is
producing and starring in a film about
the real-life jewelry thief doris payne
who's already had a documentary done
about her including her in the
documentary but man I'm very excited to
see Tessa Thompson's take on this well
I'm sure we'll have more news in the
future but this casting decision smart
move guys smart move she's amazing and
everything so I will watch her just
paint so I'm very excited in some really
like kind of catch me if you can type of
drama and stuff that'll be really fun
also this week ABC has announced that
they're rebooting the 80's cult classic
Greatest American Hero so that's kind of
a good idea
sum-sum bring some old shows back if the
story is supposed to center around 30
year old Mira who likes tequila karaoke
and not much else
all right great and starring as Mira is
going to be Hannah Simone Cece off a new
girl who is hilarious she's great she's
gonna be really that's a really really
really solid choice for her and believe
it or not she's given a super suit to
save the world
but leave it or not I wonder if they're
gonna read you that song as a theme song
no no he was iconic enough to right
stand on its own still yeah yeah
interesting
we'll see also joining the cast is going
to be George Wendt of cheers then
Zenobia Shroff from the big sick and gia
Sando who's from Indian detective so it
looks like a pretty solid cast so far
I'm really interested to see what they
do with it sounds hilarious and just
like a refreshing superhero reboot that
I have been looking for awesome
something that I have not been looking
for in my life um is a brand new Willy
Wonka movie life is moving forward it's
been in talks for a little while but now
they have a director as Paul King who is
the director of Paddington - there's no
final negotiations with him right now so
nothing is totally finalized but they're
in final negotiations so it's looking
like he's going to be the director and
they also have Simon rich who was the
writer for inside-out or one of the
writers for inside-out who's writing it
so this seems like a pretty good start
right like a good director of a kid's
movie a good writer of a kids movie but
then but then this is the part that gets
me the rumor is that it's going to be a
prequel absolutely about the origins of
Willy Wonka in the hopes that it's going
to spin off into a franchise and this
sounds awful no the mystery of his
background is part of the great draw of
it come on yeah it's one of the reasons
that it's one of the things that's great
about the plot yeah you don't know who
will
is he's just some like crazy cookie
candy maker who opens his factory up to
children in a contest I mean it's insane
I'm sure we'll get some Oompa Loompas
though yeah weird it was great everyone
cares no it's part of the mystery not
everything needs to be a franchise - we
don't need to set this up to be a
franchise there are two books - why
don't we just do a glass elevator movie
I mean I know that some of the other
ones touched on it but like you could do
a whole movie on the glass elevator just
do that I don't know it just
the last time we attempted to reboot
this we got Johnny Depp I mean being a
creeper right and no one no one wanted
that no one wanted that I'm so not
excited it seems like they had a good
foundation for the creative team behind
it but if it's a prequel no thanks
nothing that's fine I don't I don't need
that we're good yeah it's great we got a
couple of trailers this yeah and the
first one that we're going to talk about
is another reboot that's happening that
we've talked about before which is Cobra
Kai and YouTube bred and we got our
first teaser trailer on that it looks
fine I'm not gonna go out and buy
YouTube bread for it I can tell you that
right now and one of the most confusing
things to me about the trailer is that
we had reported earlier and there had
been reports earlier that this is a
sitcom yeah Dan the trailer is super
dramatic
it shows Johnny and Daniel ready to face
off again in the Cobra Kai dojo and it's
all dramatic and they have these words
that are like in steel and the deep
voice story some rivalries last a
lifetime
I thought it was supposed to be a sitcom
guy I don't what are you doing with this
right it seems like we are gonna go into
like fuller house Girl Meets World
territory with this where we're just
hopping on the nostalgia train and
hoping it takes us somewhere and it
doesn't look like it's gonna be a good
somewhere that we're gonna go I mean
we're all for nostalgia but like do it
right
I don't need to know what the fans were
in it for in the first place yeah
otherwise what doing right I mean
they're obviously trying to rely on that
nostalgia factor because even in this
first sneak peak that we got they copied
a couple of the scenes directly from
Karate Kid like it was the same setup as
Daniel and Johnny started to face each
other but like who cares if you're if
you're giving us a product show us the
product you're going to be giving us if
you're giving us a sitcom show it as a
sitcom right otherwise I'm going to go
into this thinking it's a drama right
right so what is it a sitcom or a drama
someone somewhere gave us bad
information somewhere and somewhere is
it the trailer that gave us the bad
information I don't know I don't know
it's a confused mess yeah hmm great good
look forward to that on YouTube read
soon also this week we got the
long-awaited four Incredibles 2 trailer
the full trailer finally the plot looks
very interesting kind of centering on
parenting and their family as they grow
up and superheroes including Elastigirl
who was a working mom yeah and she gets
kind of a career reboot in this and so
it's interesting to see how she now has
to you know bring in the superhero
dollars but yeah but she's got her
career back on track and so the rest of
the family has to deal with that I think
that's a really really interesting plot
point yeah working moms working moms
doing the hardest they can they get the
job done absolutely I can't wait for
that movie to drop so I'm sure well
we'll have a lot more to look forward to
that for sure also this week we got a
trailer for the drama that Samaritan
this looks oh my gosh this looks nuts
it's a burglar who kind of steals a car
as of LA right and gone breaks into the
house of a man who owns the car brand
finds a woman kidnapped and tied up but
a chained up in a room and she's like
help me please
yeah so he decides to go to the police
but they don't believe him you know he's
literally turning himself in and it's
like look I broke into this guy's house
and I found a lady what do you want me
to do
so then it looks like the man tries to
kind of Gaslight him into thinking like
nothing's going on and terrorizing him
and then the burglar kind of gets like
cornered as like harassing him and stuff
what a great concept
it looks like interesting what super
cool and David Tennant is what he's the
villain and he he plays creepy so well
and that's 100% what this role is for
him he's playing this man who is rich
and powerful and has has all the strings
in the world to pull and keep this man
this other the burglar thinking that
he's crazy and oh it looks so pretty who
is played by Robert Sheehan the Irish
actor from misfits if anyone was I love
that show um is that Jeff he's he's a
great actor so I'm really looking
forward to those two come on it's a
really cool concept and it looks so
scary it really does lastly this week we
got quite a bombshell announcement yeah
that Saban has sold toy rights to Power
Rangers from Bandai America to Hasbro
which is a huge move for them they've
had a 25-year relationship with Bandai
America and there's been some mixed
reactions to this news I'm kind of on
the fence about it I mean I'm glad
because now Power Rangers toys are gonna
get a much wider distribution because
Hasbro has a wider reach than Bandai
America ever did so we might see even
more exclusive toys online and in
certain stores that Hasbro has
relationships with but I think this
might be a nail in the coffin for Bandai
America which is a little sad for me
because I like Bandai I love Bandai
obviously they they brought the gun to
franchise to America and so I'm a little
a little bummed that this this might
mean the end of Bandai America they
didn't have too much supporting them
right now but the number one question I
have is how how are they gonna do with
the rights because bandai japan still
owns the rights to Super Sentai right so
that's what made the relationship work
between bandai japan Bandai America and
Saban right so now are they gonna have
to like double purchase the rights to
like be able to make the show and then
also
be able to make the toys or how is this
relationship going to change now that
they've kind of jumped jumped ship from
the anti America so I don't know we'll
just have to see that that actually is
not gonna happen until 2019 okay because
Bandai America had some input with the
latest Super Sentai series so they
produced the line of toys already coming
out in 2018 so it's not gonna happen
until 2019 Wow we'll see how that works
out then you know we really like that
news Walter Wow
still don't know where he is if you
think you know where Walter is be sure
you're still using the hashtag where's
Walter on social media and in the
comments down below also let us know
what you'd like to see us cover on orbit
report next how they're working people
find you on social media you can find me
on Twitter at Heather ruse Instagram at
a truce or twitch twitch.tv slash
Heather roofs and you can find me on
Facebook cuz I got away tour everywhere
else it's awesome Ayana
and send us those hashtagwars walter
ideas because we don't know we're still
looking for him so because of that you
can catch us tomorrow on top 5 in the
meantime we'll see you next week and
what's up
[Applause]
you